Welcome everybody to another jam
session
in the FP101x functional programming course.
In this snippet
I'm going to show how the ideas
that we learnt in the main course
with Haskell, can be applied
in .NET. In order to program .Net
I'll be using Xamarin Studio.
Xamarin is an open source
implementation of the .NET framework
that is cross-platform, so if you want to
write code
in C# or Visual Basic
or F# - I'll only do C# today, but
Xamarin supports the other two
languages as well -
if you want to write cross-platform
.NET code that runs on the iPhone,
on Android
on Windows Phone, on the Mac or Windows, Xamarin studio
is your tool of choice. Because of
that
Xamarin Studio is also my tool of
choice.
Let's sit down,
open up Xamarin Studio and write some
C# code
using functions. C#
has a couple of interesting twists
that we haven't seen
in other languages. Here is our
Xamarin Studio,
and here is some sample
C# code.
As always,
C# requires a main method.
It doesn't require
you to pass the arguments if you don't
use them. Here's the typical hello
world:
Console.WriteLine("Hello World!") and
f here is our first example of a lambda expression, so
the right inside here x => x * 2
is a lambda expression that multiplies
the argument by two and I assign it
to f. Here's another form of a lambda
expression that defines a function from
int to int h and and it takes a
parameter x and then
it uses a statement body
with curly braces. Those are the two forms of lambda expressions and here I
print f
and h. C# does support
type inference, so I can write
var z
equals 42 and when I do this,
you see that
it has inferred... The
editor here says that this is
redundant because I'm not using z
anywhere,
but what I wanted to show you is that
you can define
var here and the compiler
will infer that z has type int.
Now you can
ask yourself why can't we use type
inference here. Let's
try to
write var here
and let's not forget the type.
There is our var and let's run this
code. Now what you see here is that
it says: implicitly typed local variable
declaration
cannot be initialized with anonymous
method.
What does that all mean? Well, the
thing here is that in C#
I can use a lambda expression,
like we do below here.
Here I define another lambda
expression; it's exactly the same
lambda expression as here, but instead of
giving it the type of Func from int to int,
I say it's an expression
of Func from int to int. This is
a super interesting aspect of C#
where a lambda expression by itself
has no type - that's why I couldn't use
type inference there -
but depending on the context where you use this lambda
expression, that lambda expression can be
turned
into code - like here, into a function -
or it can be turned into data
- like here, into an expression.
The price you pay
for that magic, where you can take
a lambda expression and represent it
as code and
as data, is the fact that you have to
explicitly type them.
Let's have a little look here at g
and see
what intellisense tells us. So what you
see here now
is that g has a body - so let's
get g's body - and then
here we see that we have all kind of
methods
on g. For example, we can reduce, et
cetera.
This gives you a full API
to manipulate this lambda expression
as data. This mechanism is used very
heavily for example,
in frameworks like the Entity Framework,
and in the olden days, in LINQ to SQL,
where you can take fragments like this,
analyze them
and compile them to SQL.
Satnam Singh at
Microsoft Research has also done some
interesting work here for example, where
he takes these
lambda expressions and compiles them
into FPGAs
and people do all kinds of interesting
things.
If you are a lisp programmer,
the way you would do this is using
quoting
and this is kind of C#'s way of
doing quoting
using static types.
One thing that C# doesn't have
and which we saw
in other languages, that did work,
for example in Kotlin,
in Scala, in Dart, is the idea of
local functions. So you can have a lambda
expression here,
which is kind of a local function, but I
cannot define
a function, or method, just
like I defined here -  inside another
method.
Suppose I wanted to define h here,
that's nested inside
main - you see already here that I get a
syntax error
that you cannot do this. Oh well,
I've already defined h, so
let's call this k, but I
still cannot do that
because now it gives me a
proper parse error
saying that you cannot have local
function declarations. I think that's
something that I do miss
in C#, because now if you want to
declare a
method like that you have to lift everything
to the top level. What else can we say
about C#? Well...comprehensions, so in C#
when I say here var xs =
new array
.
So here we
have an array xs, of the values 1 to 5
- you see that it's full type inferenced, I don't
have to specify any types.
Now i can say var ys =
from x in xs where
x < 4 select
x * 2. Here you see
the comprehension syntax
in C#. It looks a little bit like
SQL
and that's on purpose
- these are called LINQ
comprehension - but they work exactly the
same way
as Haskell list comprehensions.
Talking about
comprehensions, C#, of
course,
also supports the range of higher-order
functions that we
know and love from Haskell. In this
case, if we look at the
inferred type for ys, that has type
enumerable of int. If we use
intellisense to show
the methods that are
available there, we see
that there are a lot of methods in here.
C# calls them
slightly different then Haskell
and other languages:
instead of map, C#
uses Select and
the pop-up there is a little bit small,
but Select
is the version of map and it takes
a function.
Bind or flatMap
is called SelectMany - if we look here
there's SelectMany -
and instead of filter, C#
uses Where. Except for this little
alpha renaming
of these methods, all the higher-order
functions over collections and even more,
like GroupBy and
joins, are all available
in the standard library.
So if you want to give C# or
Visual Basic,
or F# a try, you can
immediately apply all the things
that you learned
in the Haskell part of the course
to programming in these .NET
languages.
Thank you and see you next time!